all morning Nordine has been running
from one government distribution center
to another but he keeps being turned
away the aide is being taken to other
places there's food and water in this
truck do you know where they're going I
don't know what we do know is all the
aid from this place is going to the main
Relief Center
he shows us a whole list of things he
desperately needs for himself and his
family 24 people it's signed and stamped
but he still ends up with nothing
I registered and started queueing
yesterday but I was told to come back
today when I was here early in the
morning they told me had come to the
wrong place they said I should have gone
to a different distribution center
distribution centers like this one all
around the city people are lining up to
get supplies but because coordination of
eight distribution is still an issue
many end up empty-handed
like Nordine he takes me home to meet
his family
they've all been living under a tarp
since the earthquake especially the
children are traumatized
whereas okay even when there is no
earthquake or aftershock I always feel
like the ground is moving I'm really
afraid then I realized there is no
earthquake but because I'm so afraid I'm
imagining it I feel like it's always
moving I'm scared to go inside a house
by myself I only go with my parents if
they're not with me I won't go in there
telling me they're running low on food
and drinking water it's the smallest who
suffer the most many of the children are
sick and hungry
the youngest t-ara is only one month old
my baby isn't in very good health at the
moment she has a rash because of the
heat we need milk diapers medicine and
other things for her but then they like
to go Bhutan by Noreen's family are not
alone in their fear and despair all over
Paulo thousands are camping out and
supplies are scarce at every turn
nowhere is this more obvious than at the
city's gas stations the distribution of
the valuable commodity is heavily
guarded price is that this regulated
pump are as always but on the black
market gas sells for up to five times as
much fuel is a lifeline some people here
have been waiting for seven hours just
to get five liters of gas they need it
not only to power their motorbikes and
cars but also generators that create
electricity so they can charge for
example their mobile phones to stay in
touch and receive updates on the
situation from the authorities the lines
here are endless at the moment we're at
number 789 and there are many more
canisters and serif' here is the one
writing the numbers on them but at the
moment he can't because his pen has run
out yet another hiccup if ever so slight
in their attempt to organize the chaos
but with more help promised the people
here hope they can soon start to rebuild
their ravaged lives